we've all seen a magician presented deck
of cards with a flourish that's just the
beginning in the mesmerizing art of
cardistry the way I would describe
artistry is an expression of technical
skill with the deck of cards meant to
show off its juggling with playing cards
over the last decade a small group of
fanatics has turned simple shuffling
into freaky performance art the way the
art form has grown just by sharing
through social media YouTube Instagram
things like that so we thought it would
be an awesome idea for all these amazing
artists to get together under one roof
and just meet each other and share their
passion card is from around the globe
recently gathered in Brooklyn
to swap tips at the first official
cardistry convention cardistry has
become my life it's not only fun just
for me but to come up with a new move
that like makes my friend in Denmark
like impress that is why I continue to
do cardistry
cardistry grew out of magicians
flourishes but today distances itself
from sleight of hand
yeah card flourishes was always sort of
like within card magic it was a way to
accent a point it wasn't until 10 or so
years ago that guys like Dave and I and
some of the guys coming to this event
really started taking those ideas and
just running with them
these days happening with Instagram
especially is that concepts you know
once they're at a presentable level can
be posted like right away and be viewed
by like you know people across the globe
what people are going for is the impact
the aesthetics the visual like you know
arrangement and design of what's
happening one of my favorite things
about cars tree is as long as you have a
deck of cards you can do it anywhere so
it's like I have you know an endless
supply of
blank canvases in my pocket just ready
to be painted it's it's really fun
because it just never gets old